who's excited i know we are the first  new property on the strip  in a decade opens in just two days and  there's a big party in the works resorts  world will greet visitors this thursday  and the amenities they'll enjoy are  endless with more than 3 000 rooms and  suites  a five and a half acre pool complex  cashless gaming and  all sorts of fun food options president  scott sabella hopes  the state-of-the-art technology and the  list of impressive residencies  will bring a business boom to the north  end of the strip  we're excited and again it won't happen  overnight but business will shift this  way  in the future i think this will be the  luxury side of the strip  well this new property sits on the side  of the former stardust hotel which  opened back in 1958  we're told the resort does pay tribute  to some of its earlier history  with nods to elvis and wayne newton